do you think there will be a war with
China in the 21st century I don't know
uh my argument is there will be there is
right now a serious security
competition and uh at the same time
there is a real possibility of War
whether or not we avoid it is very hard
to say uh I mean we did during the Cold
War we had a serious security
competition from roughly 194 7 to
1989 and uh and we thankfully avoided
war probably came the closest in 1962
with the Cuban Missile
Crisis but uh we avoided it and I think
we can avoid it here is it for sure no
you've said that China won't move on
Taiwan militarily in part because it's
uh as you said amphibious operations are
difficult why will China not move on
Taiwan is in your
sense uh in the near future well it's
because there's this body of water
called the Taiwan straigh which is a big
body of water and getting across water
uh is very difficult unless you can walk
on water so geography still has a role
to play in the 21st century oh yeah I
think geography is very important big
bodies of water really matter yeah in an
Ideal World you'd like to have the
Pacific Ocean between you and any
potential adversary you know 6,000 miles
yes 6,000 Mi of water hard to get across
yes I if you're a country and I'm a
country and there's land between us I
can take my Panzer divisions and I can
go right across the land and get into
your country or attack your country and
you of course can take your Panzer
divisions and come across that same
piece of land but if there's a big body
of water between us your Panzer
divisions can't go across the water and
then the question is how do you get them
across the water and that's very tricky
and in a world we have lots of
submarines and you have lots of aircraft
and you have missiles that are landbased
that can hit those surface ships it is
very very hard to you know to attack
across a body of water and all you have
to do is think about uh Normandy you
know the American invasion of Normandy
June 6th 1944 coming in on Omaha Beach
right uh oh boy that was really
difficult but there is a growing
asymmetry of military
power there that even though it's
difficult that is correct so I I guess
that is correct so I recently had a
conversation with Elon Musk and and he
says
that uh you know China is quite serious
about the one China policy and it's
seems inevitable that Taiwan will have
to be if you look at this pragmatically
in the 21st century it seems inevitable
that Taiwan will have to be a part of
China and so we can get there either
diplomatically or militarily like
um what do you think about the
inevitability of that kind of idea when
a nation says this is a top
priority for us
um what do you think about
them meaning
it and what do we do about that there's
no question it's a top priority for them
and there's no question they mean it but
it's also a top priority for us not to
let them take Taiwan why exactly because
it's an important strategic asset uh
many people will say it's because
taiwan's a democracy but that doesn't
matter that
much uh it's
because uh of two strategic reasons the
first is
that uh if we were to let Taiwan
go it would have hugely negative
consequences for our alliance structure
in East Asia to contain China we need
allies we have an alliance structure in
a allies Japanese South
Koreans Filipinos
Australians they're all counting on us
to be there for them and if we say we're
not going to defend Taiwan the Chinese
attack
they're going to say I bet if the
Chinese attack us the Americans won't be
there for us uh so the it would have
uh a damaging effect on our alliance
structure which we cannot afford because
because containing China is a wicked
problem it's a powerful State you were
getting to this before when you talked
about China versus Taiwan so that's the
first reason second reason is you want
to bottle up the Chinese Navy in the
Chinese Air Force inside the first
island chain you don't want to let them
get
out uh into the Pacific you don't want
them dominating the Waters of East Asia
you want to bottle them up again inside
the first island chain and you can only
do that if you control Taiwan you don't
control Taiwan they get out into the
Philippine Sea into the Pacific and the
Western Pacific and cause all sorts of
problems well you saying all that you've
also said the century of humiliation
Japan and the United States are source
of that humiliation for
China don't you think they see the other
side of that absolutely and in the
interest of avoiding a World
War I guess the question is uh how do we
avoid a World War it
doesn't um seem like the military invol
involvement in the conflict between
China and Taiwan is the
way well I I don't want there's no good
answers here I'm just saying there are
no good which is the the less bad option
well what you want to do is you want to
make sure that you
deter uh China from invading Taiwan you
want to avoid a war you and I are in
complete agreement on that we don't want
a war but we want to contain China we do
not want to let China dominate Asia that
that's what the Americans are
principally concerned with here and it's
what China's neighbors are principally
concerned with and this includes the
Japanese the South Koreans Filipinos
Australians and the Taiwan e we they
don't want and we don't want China to
dominate the region so we have to
contain it but at the same time and this
should be music to your ears we not only
want to contain it we want to make sure
we don't end up in a shooting match with
the Chinese because this could be
disastrous so you have to have a very
smart policy you have to build powerful
military forces and you have to make
sure you don't do anything that's
provocative on Taiwan for example the
last thing you want is for the Taiwanese
government to declare its independence
because the Chinese have said if Taiwan
does that we'll go to war and of course
we don't want that so my view is you
want to smartly build up your military
forces and you want to do everything you
can to contain China uh and at the same
time not be provocative
so a big component of that is making uh
sure your military the US military is
bigger than the Chinese
military not necessarily um it's an
interesting
question uh a lot of people think that
to make deterrence work right you have
to be able to beat the Chinese and
therefore you need a much bigger
military uh and I don't think over time
that's possible right I think it's
probably not even possible now to beat
the Chinese in a war over Taiwan or in a
war in the South China Sea I think what
you want to do is make it clear to the
Chinese either that there will be no
winner in other words you don't have to
win but you want to make sure they don't
win okay it's it's it's a l lose uh
proposition if they go to war over
Taiwan or what have you uh and if you
can't do that right you think that
they're so powerful that they're
ultimately going to win you want to
convince them that Victory would be a
pic victory in other words they would
pay a god- awul price to win the war you
follow what I'm saying so excuse me the
best strategy for deterrence is you win
China loses second best strategy is a
stalemate nobody wins third best
strategy is they win but they pay a god-
awful price and the fourth possibility
which you don't want is they went
quickly and decisively right uh if
that's the case then you don't have much
deterrence